HELP LOS ANGELES TO HELP FOLKS
ON THE WEST COAST.
MARK, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ARTHEL: ERIC, THANK YOU, FDA
APPROVING CORONAVIRUS TEST THAT
COULD GIVE RESULTS IN ABOUT 15
MINUTES.
THE PHARMACEUTICAL COMPANY
BEHIND IT NOW RAMPING UP
PRODUCTION SAYING IT EXPECTS TO
DELIVER 50,000 TESTS STARTING
NEXT WEEK.
LET’S GO TO STEVE HARRIGAN LIVE
IN ATLANTA OUTSIDE OF CDC
HEADQUARTERS, STEVE.
STEVE: ARTHEL, THAT NEWS REALLY
SHOWS JUST HOW DRAMATICALLY AND
QUICKLY THINGS ARE CHANGING WHEN
IT COMES TO TESTING.
A COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO IT WAS
DAYS WAIT FOR A LAB RESULT TO
COME BACK.
JUST LAST WEEK FDA APPROVING FOR
THE FIRST TIME A TEST THAT COULD
COME IN 45 MINUTES, SO-CALLED
POINT OF CARE TEST THAT WOULD
LET YOU KNOW WITHIN THAT AMOUNT
OF TIME WHETHER OR NOT YOU HAVE
THE VIRUS.
NOW LAB SAYING THEY ARE READY
FOR A TEST THAT CAN COME UNDER
15 MINUTES, POSITIVE RESULT IN
AS LITTLE AS 5 MINUTES.
THIS REALLY COULD BE A
GAME-CHANGER.
THE LAB SAYS IT’S GOING TO ROLL
OUT 50,000 TEST UNITS A DAY, FDA
APPROVED BEGINNING ON MONDAY.
ALSO THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION SAYING IT’S
BEGINNING HISTORIC DRUG TRIAL
TREATMENTS.
VOLUNTEERS FROM NORWAY AND SPAIN
GETTING THOSE TREATMENTS TO SEE
WHAT WORKS THE BEST AGAINST
CORONAVIRUS.
FOUR OF THE MOST PROMISING DRUGS
WILL BE TESTED IN THESE TRIALS,
MALARIA MEDICATIONS, ANTIVIRAL
COMPOUNDS AS WELL AS HIV
COMPOUNDS, ALL BEING TEST TODAY
SEE WHICH IS THE MOST EFFECTIVE
AGAINST THE CORONAVIRUS, ARTHEL,